[Musique]
il était un contemporain de Louis XIV
Noël Capel artiste peintre du 17e siècle
né en 1628 et mort en 1707 il laisse
derrière lui une longue carrière de 79
ans tout au long de sa vie il mettra son
talent au service du Roi Soleil et de
l'église c'était vraiment un des
peintres importants qui a la carrière
académique qu'apprécie tout grand
peintre du 17e il peint son morceau de
réception pour rentrer à l'Académie puis
professeur puis directeur de l'Académie
de France à Rome puis directeur même de
l'Académie royale de peinture et de
sculpture à Paris donc une très belle
carrière d'un point de vue officiel
fondateur d'une dynastie de peintrre
Noël coapel brille dans plusieurs
domaines peinture sur cheval et peinture
murale ce qui fera de lui l'un des
peintres les plus affluants de son
siècle c'est sa rencontre avec Charles
herrard qui le fera travailler au
château il s'occupera essentiellement
des grands décors notamment ceux de la
chambre du roi lorsqu rard charlesard
aura été écarté par Charles lebrin on
l'envoyant comme directeur de l'Académie
de France à Rome comme ça bien loin de
de Paris et de Versailles Capel va
passer sous la la houlette si je puis
dire de Charles lebrin et aura deux
salons à décorer dans le grand
appartement du roi du Parlement de
Bretagne à Rennes au demeur royale c'est
seulement à la fin de sa vie qui
s'occupera des invalide certaines de ces
œuvres ont aujourd'hui disparu il reste
néanmoins plusieurs grands décors comme
le tableau la rosé ici c'est un des
tableau de la série d'Hercule il reçoit
cette commande en
1688 il mettra beaucoup de temps à la
peindre à tel point qu'en fait
l'ensemble ne sera pas mis en place au
Trianon sous bois qui est une des ailes
du Grand Trianon des tableaux
d'exception pour un palais d'exception
exposés dans un décor qu'il a lui-même
réalisé
à travers une sélection de 90 œuvres
uniques l'exposition retrace l'histoire
de la peinture de l'artiste dans un
décor Royal celle-ci durera jusqu'au 28
janvier